BORDER BUT A PROBLEM FOR THE
ENTIRE NATION.
BACK TO YOU IN NEW YORK.
>> Martha: LET'S GET THE READ ON
ALL OF THIS NOW FROM FORMER
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR, RON
VITELLO.
THIS NOTION THAT MAGNUS IS
PUSHING BACK AS HARD AS HE IS.
I SAW A QUOTE TO MAYORKAS, I
EXPRESSED TO HIM THAT I FELT
THERE WAS NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
ME TO RESIGN WHEN I STILL CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THE WORK I WAS
DOING AND FELT THAT THE WORK WAS
FOCUSED ON THE THINGS I WAS
HIRED TO DO IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT LAST PART OF THE SENTENCE
IS INTERESTING.
BECAUSE MAYBE HE'S DOING THE
BIDDING OF THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
IS A WHITE HOUSE THAT HAS ROLLED
OUT THE RET CARPET FOR UNLIMITED
MIGRATION THROUGH THE SOUTHERN
BORDERS.
IS HE THE FALL GUY HERE?
>> IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
LET'S THINK ABOUT WHY HE'S
THERE.
HE'S A PROGRESSIVE POLICE CHIEF
THAT IS CRITICAL OF THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR BORDER
POLICY AND WAS ON THE RECORD IN
A NUMBER OF PLACES SAYING HE
DIDN'T WANT TO COOPERATE WITH
ICE.
SO HE'S ON RECORD SAYING THAT HE
WANTS TO CONTINUE TO HAVE AN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT IS
BROKEN.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A CREDIBLE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO CONTROL THE BORDER?
HOW HAS HE DONE SINCE HE'S BEEN
THERE?
WE ARE IN THE WORST SURGE ALONG
THE SOUTHWEST BORNER FOR ILLEGAL
MIGRATION IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE 60,000 AMERICANS DYING
EVERY YEAR FROM OPIOID OVERDOSE.
SO THERE'S -- THAT'S NOT A CO
INCIDENT.
WE HAVE THIS UNCONTROLLED FLOW
AT THE BORDER AND WE HAVE PEOPLE
DYING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
HUNDREDS A WEEK.
AND WHAT IS THIS PUBLIC FACE TO
THE REST OF US?
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL, HIS
LARGEST PRESS CONFERENCE IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WAS
ON A FAKE NEWS STORY ABOUT HORSE
PATROL AGENTS IN DEL RIO ACCUSED
OF A CRIME THEY DIDN'T COMMIT.
THAT'S WHAT THE WORK FORCE SEES.
HOW ABOUT A 40-MINUTE PRESS
CONFERENCE HOW HE WILL SECURE
THE BOREDER?
HE SERVES AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THE CABINET SECRETARY HAS ASKED
HIM TO STEP DOWN FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
HE SERVES AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER HERE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF CBP THAT TOOK AND
OATH AND DEDICATED TO SECURING
THE BORDER.
WE'RE BEING DISEXTRACTSED BY
REARRANGING THE DECK CHAIRS ON
THE TITANIC.
WE HAVE A TERRIBLE CRISIS GOING
ON AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LEADER AT CBP.
THE WORK FORCE DESERVES BETTER
THAN THIS.
AGAIN --
>> Charles: RON, CAN THE WORK
FORCE EXPECT BETTER?
TO YOUR POINT, IN DECEMBER 2017,
HE PUBLISHED IN "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AN OP-ED VERY CRITICAL OF
DONALD TRUMP AND JEFF SESSIONS
WITH RESPECT TO SANCTUARY CITIES
SAYING THEY COMPLICATE POLICE
FORCES, THIS IS THE IDEAL GUY
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION.
HE CHECKED THEIR BOXES.
SHOULD THE FOX AT THE BORDER
PATROL BRACE FOR SOMEONE EVEN
FURTHER TO THE LEFT OR IS THIS
JUST FOR PUBLIC CONSUMPTION THAT
NOTHING REALLY WILL CHANGE?
>> THE POLICY AT THE BORDER IS
ALL WRONG.
YEAH, THERE'S A DANGER.
THIS IS PART OF THE DISTRACTION.
PEOPLE -- MEN AND WOMEN AT CBP
THAT HAVE TAKEN AN OATH, THEY
WANT ACTION.
THEY DON'T NEED THIS
DISTRACTION.
WE NEED A PLAN.
WE NEED TO SECURE THE BORDER.
HE'S FAILED TO DO IT.
I'M SURE HE'S NOT SETTING THE
POLICY.
THIS ADMINISTRATION RIPPED UP
ALL OF THE TOOLS THAT WE HAD
BEFORE THEY TOOK OVER.
NOW AGAIN, WE'RE SEEING THE
WORST THING WE'VE EVER SEEN AND
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHO THE
COMMISSIONER IS INSTEAD OF WHAT
THE PLANS ARE TO SECURE THE U.S.
BORDER.
>> Martha: IS THERE ANY HOPE
THOUGH THAT THIS WILL CHANGE?
THIS HAS BEEN A PROMINENT PIECE
OF NEWS OBVIOUSLY.
IT HAD IMPACT WITH THE
ELECTIONS.
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS -- I
BELIEVE THIS HAS TO BE WHAT THEY
WANT TO SEE.
THIS HAS TO BE FULFILLING SOME
SORT OF PROGRESSIVE DREAM OF
OPEN BORDERS AND PEOPLE FLOODING
THROUGH.
>> WELL, THE WORK FORCE DESERVES
BETTER.
OUR COUNTRY DESERVES BETTER.
THINK ABOUT THE CELEBRATION
TODAY FOR ALL OF OUR VETERANS.
HERE WE ARE WITH A BORDER OUT OF
CONTROL.
THEY WENT OUT AND GA